people across the world are mourning
today's loss of queen elizabeth ii
britain's longest serving monarch died
in scotland at the age of 96. now her
son charles takes the throne las vegas
not holding back on their love for the
queen as well brits and our community
are coming together to remember her
christian casares joining us live in
studio with more on how she is being
remembered and what she meant christian
for our community that's right many
people told us there is no doubt queen
elizabeth ii had a monumental impact and
is forever engraved in our minds that's
how one local brit is remembering her
and says there is no doubt the u.s loves
the queen
it's been an incredible journey the
queen to me is more than my numb 82 year
old brian tate is heartbroken after
hearing about the passing of queen
elizabeth on thursday a true leader he
says a monarch for the people and by the
people when i look at my queen it's
worked so hard and to me she's been
truly the backbone of england and the
commonwealth inside the crowded anchor
pub on maryland and flamingo the queen's
image is visible above the dining room
and even at the entrance we have the cut
out of the queen so people were taking
pictures like the queen was here general
manager june lemay says any royal family
event means big business and her death
will generate a large crowd for support
tonight will be very very busy because
they all want to come you know pay their
respects and everything to the queen so
this is like a gathering place for brits
and americans a perfect time lemay says
to also share personal moments about her
majesty it was poppy day and we were
walking in the village and the car came
by and it was the queen and she said
what was that for you that was amazing
there are an estimated 30 000 brits in
southern nevada according to mark
mcgarry who runs facebook group las
vegas curry club and hopes to connect
with all during this rough time we all
come together and we help each other out
she's engraved in everybody's minds
whether they love her or hate her
well you heard the crown and anchor pub
manager there say tonight will be very
busy well they are expecting a gathering
there at six o'clock tonight and it will
continue throughout the next 10 days
until the funeral christian casadas 8
news now